and i was just trying to see if you had
any advice on getting of your first love
honestly
i was 18 when i first met this girl and
now i'm 20 and
she was my first everything first
girlfriend first
love we had gotten a dog together and
everything i thought
we were in it for the long run you know
and she finally broke up with me
oh you got that dog together
this is something that's going on these
days uh
this is something that is going on a
relationship animal
and you gotta shut it down if it's a
real type of animal if it's a fish dude
or you and your girl
you know y'all split a cricket or
something you know where y'all go half
she's on a little oyster
you know or a lazard bruh that's fine
but once you go and get a puppy or
something that can really look at you
and maybe remember a little bit of [ __ ]
you know a strong mouse or whatever
you're creating havoc within the nk
brother the nature kingdom because you
because you got a joint animal
now you got the animal she's got the
animal y'all split up what is that now
he's doing what
now he's all scared he starts wetting
the bed at night
you know he he he he hears y'all arguing
in the kitchen and [ __ ]
you know he he he starts eating alone at
school
you know he starts going home with other
animals that he's not even really
interested in
you know he starts hiding under the bed
he starts you know he sees y'all going
all separate ways
you know it's just if you get a
relationship animal it's dangerous
you know you know you now you got an
american water spaniel or whatever he
thinks it's his fault
you know he doesn't you know he quits uh
you know
he's staying up late at night and
reading you know reading scary novels
you know you if you a relationship
animal it's just
it's not that you can't put that kind of
pressure on an animal if you don't know
you're married to the person or whatever
bring your own animals into a
relationship you don't get an animal
once you're together
now all that it just it's too much on
that animal's back
you know now you got you know next thing
you know you got a raccoon out there
he's vaping by the recycling bin
because he can't handle his emotions
because he doesn't know you know who
still cares about him
you know sure your little parakeet's
getting two christmases now but
it just i think the
the risks of of it
outweigh the reward
yeah and these relationship animals the
two owners they start fighting and they
start giving both of them
are giving the animal a treat oh here i
got a treat for you you love me you love
danny don't you
and then oh i got a treat for you you
love sandra
and then the animal doesn't know what to
do is just treat it out now it's all
hopped up on treats it's gained 30 40
pounds
and next thing you know is down there at
the damn methadone clinic
so it's just you can't don't get a
relationship animal
just that's really all all that place is
going to be is just a cul-de-sac where
you get where you and your partner
just drive by and just throw y'all's
[ __ ] problems out into the street
that's all that relationship animal is
so if you're going to get an animal get
an animal for yourself
don't get this little halfway house you
know living
creature that both you guys are just
using passively
aggressively towards one another
don't get because all you're really
getting is just a little passive
aggressive pet
where you guys are descending it this
way and sending it that way
you know just a little paul revere or
whatever yeah next and next thing you
know it's lashing out
you know it's at the parakeet park or
whatever the dog park
you know it's biting other things it's
[ __ ] stealing fruit or something over
by the um
vons or by the um you know it's stealing
fruit over there by a winn-dixie
it's just you don't do it
you know it's just you're better than
that you are better than that and this
animal deserves better
and it'll start thinking if it's if it's
his fault you know you'll see sometimes
some of these
you know these animals these
relationship animals
and they're out there you'll see them
over there i see them off at a 101 at
night sometimes
you know kicking a can down a side of
the interstate you know just
[Music]
just i don't know i think there's just
better ways to go about it good evening
good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one